[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages in the next half hour then
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the director of the demos think
tank polly mckenzie and the economist at
the article ali mirage great to see you
happy new year of course to to both of
you so front pages then let us kick off
with the observer which reports that all
secondary school pupils in england
should go back to wearing face masks in
class according to new advice from the
government
that is also the lead story for the
telegraph which says that children will
be forced back into masks and lessons
daily
leads on an nhs chief's warning that
further covet restrictions could be
needed if the number of patients in
hospital keeps rising the times leads
with the increasing pressure on the
struggling nhs as one in 10 of its staff
goes sick with covid
according to scotland on sunday the
number of refugees that have resettled
in scotland has significantly dropped
during the pandemic
the mirror has an exclusive from the
ex-partner of prince andrew's accuser
virginia gifrey who backs her
allegations that the duke of york abused
her
well sunday the sunday people has the
headline andrew must go the words it
says of a number of senior military
figures we should stress that prince
andrew denies all claims made against
him
and the star reporting that thousands of
young people believe the world is ruled
by alien lizards
so we're joined then by the director of
the demos think tank polly mckenzie and
the columnist at the article ali mirage
welcome to both of you um so a number of
the newspapers then ali leading on this
news uh that schools have been told that
face masks need to be back in classrooms
that's right and i think the teams of
hawaii is in a difficult position the
new education secretary he desperately
wants to keep education going uh we know
all the impacts that lockdown's had on
school kids in terms of access to
online learning uh also access to ipads
and and technology etc so it's really
really important for kids well-being
both physical and mental that they are
in school
this measure is being brought in in
secondary schools where kids are going
to be uh asked to wear masks again
there's also going to be more focus on
providing extra ventilation equipment i
think 7 000 extra pieces of ventilation
equipment going to be doled out to
schools uh but there's some questions
being asked about this robert half on
the chair of the education select
committee has been asking well uh why do
we need to actually introduce these face
masters schools when they're not
introduced in restaurants or offices
although robert halphon does miss the
point that we're meant to be working
from home at the moment so i don't think
it quite follows his argument but
certainly this is going to play into a
much broader issue for the government
about introducing further restrictions
if those indeed do come in where they're
going to be a lot of resistance from
their own back benches remember just
before christmas a hundred tory
backbenchers almost uh voted uh almost
100 rather voted against the
introduction vaccine passport so it's
going to be a really interesting few
days for the government to manage this
yeah and it does appear doesn't it that
uh certainly a number of the unions have
welcomed this um that the the lack of
mitigations in schools you know has
perhaps been stressful for teachers for
parents as well uh and it goes further
six trade unions representing education
staff across the country want uh polly
more money from the government to help
pay for the costs of supply staff to
cover for covered absences it's almost
like they are predicting or they expect
and anticipate with the the levels of
community affection we have now that
staff absences might be quite high
i think they're right to to predict that
we're seeing across a whole range of
public services
that even if covid infections aren't
thank goodness because of vaccines
leading to the same number of hospital
admissions icu treatment and deaths as
it did in previous waves the very fact
of being infected isolating potentially
being quite ill for a number of days
just has a huge impact on sickness
absence and therefore the ability to
deliver trains and hospitals and
post offices whatever it might be
i think you have to think about this not
through a political lens around the
desirability of wearing face masks which
you know they're kind of annoying um but
through the question of how do we keep
schools as open and high functioning as
possible because even though older
people have borne the health costs of
this pandemic it is young people who
have borne the long-term consequences
and you know two years of utterly
shambolic totally disrupted exam
timetables we cannot have that spread
into a third year so everything we can
do to keep the most high quality
schooling the most face-to-face
schooling uh open for kids uh is
absolutely essential and actually having
teachers on board for that feeling
confident and comfortable in the
classroom that's not a bad thing it's
not a bad thing if the teaching unions
are pleased in support of the teachers
um the masks you know we know that they
are not complete prophylactic they do
not completely prevent infection
spreading but they can reduce it they
can keep a few more teachers in the
classroom a few more pupils in the
classroom and that's got to be worth
doing to absolutely do everything we can
to minimize the risks it's easy to look
backwards and say we should have done
more work on ventilation we should have
had more work going into supply teachers
or this movement to get retired teachers
back but we you know
that's no good right it's just hindsight
where we are now anything we can do to
mobilize more teachers into into those
classrooms is really important and it's
really difficult to find supply teachers
when every school is in the same kind of
scenario and those supply teachers are
super super expensive when everybody
wants them so i i think you know the
government must look at those requests
from unions really quite seriously
or support schools if they have to you
know go over budget and just manage
things in the short term because the
most important thing just to come back
to it is that we keep schools open for
face-to-face learning for our kids who
absolutely have to be there yes and the
the express which we saw there does
remind us that the advice remains in
place until january the 26th when the
plan b regulations are due to expire
they also quote a professor of
psychology at nottingham university
saying that this is not a neutral
intervention masks impair communication
and development some children find them
frightening or distressing and
interestingly i see ali that that the
french authorities have announced that
they've um brought down the age at which
children were faced whilst there that
children six and older now will have to
wear mosques in indoor places open to
the public um which is i mean that's
very young isn't it to get kids to to
you know enter buildings and put a face
mask on
well it's not just that anna it's also
the question about uh immunization of
under-12s as well which we don't have a
subtle view on yet in our country uh the
medical uh profession seems to be quite
split on the issue and there's no
settled view i think this is going to be
a difficult one for the government to
navigate for a couple of reasons firstly
as i mentioned its own back benches and
there are we know there are a hundred of
them there could be more uh part of them
in this covid recovery group that are
really quite vociferous about any new
restrictions whatsoever and that's been
driven partly by a philosophical
view about freedom
but also fundamentally about economics
and i was talking to you know i take an
interest in
all things related to nightclubs i was
talking to a founder of my favorite uh
dance music record they were defected um
in the last couple of days you said that
we now need to move beyond the world of
lockdowns a coven has caused a lot of
suffering not only medical related
suffering also suffering to people's
jobs in the economy and this also
applies to kids as well in schools and i
think we just need to get to a position
where we have to live with this virus
sensibly the other issue is whether
there will be public compliance with any
further restrictions if you look at some
of the polling coming out you gov one a
few days back was saying that now the
consensus amongst the public majority of
the public are not in favor of any more
stringent restrictions plan b seems to
be just about acceptable but further
restrictions and lockdowns is not going
to be and you can look at the pressure
that the welsh and scottish governments
have come under for their more draconian
stance they've taken when they had a
bunch of people coming across the border
to go clubbing last night in england so
i think we've got to get to a position
where we live with the virus take
sensible precautions but get on with our
lives yeah i mean it's difficult to to
make that point when the case load is so
high and we're waiting for the data to
sort of unwash from the holiday period
aren't we and i think everyone will be
in a better position you know perhaps at
the back end of next week to really see
where we're at in terms of
hospitalization trends and so on so
we'll you know we'll we'll watch this
space certainly do you mind if we move
on uh to the sunday telegraph polly and
talk about the cost of living crisis
fuel bills again what's this uh this
about
so the uh some conservative backbenchers
uh are now making the case that the
government should do
more to tackle the cost of living crisis
in particular around fuel bills and you
know this is something i think we're
going to come back to over all of the
first months of this year this is when
energy bills are their highest because
it's cold so people turn the heating on
more and particularly people on um on
kind of pre-pay meters really really
face the cost of that on in a day-to-day
way and energy bills there's just
there's currently no pathway to bring
them down the energy cap which we know
has been
really hurting supplier companies pushed
lots and lots of them out of businesses
will go up as a result of the continued
high wholesale prices and that's going
to cause huge political pain for people
there's some polling in the mail on
sunday today as well um uh what tomorrow
sorry um which again which goes into the
question of that cost of living crisis
and people's concerns about that
particularly in the red wall
and
in the last couple of weeks we've had
the labour party putting pressure on the
government saying that uh vat should be
cut on fuel bills to uh reduce some of
the pressure on on the cost of living
but we're now seeing kind of pincer
movement it's actually the tory right
particularly some kind of climate
skeptics who are worried about all of
the um
their green costs that are loaded onto
our energy bills who are now saying that
something needs to be done about energy
bills as well so it's quite hard to see
a good policy intervention that actually
helps people quickly because this is
kind of global political trend around
the cost of energy but nevertheless it's
really clear that political pressure is
piling on from every direction now okay
can we very quickly do tony blair what
do you reckon uh just a very quick one
uh ali uh it's in the express number of
front pages too um the controversial uh
awarding of an order of the garter as a
knight companion
well he did actually have a
transformational impact on british
politics won three general elections
most successful labor leader for decades
so i think it's quite right they should
be knighted however i think his epitaph
will always be iraq and one name is
conspicuous by its absence from the
honours list yet again and i'm not a
brexiteer i did not vote to leave the eu
but nigel farage has yet again not been
recognized and i must say i'm slightly
put out um
myself on it that i wasn't nominated for
an honor for services to the press
preview on skype okay
a lot more on that uh to come in the
future no doubt how pharma farmers also
ahead could spin straw into gold by
re-worlding the countryside that is on
the front page of the telegraph we will
look at that next
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the director
of the demos think tank polly mckenzie
and the columnist at the article ali
morosh welcome back to both of you um so
polly let's go to the sunday telegraph
shall we and uh a story here about
rewilding
natural habitats uh what what's the
suggestion
well this is really great news i think
uh as a result of brexit which i'm not
in favor of but the one really good
thing is our ability to reform the way
we subsidize farming in this country
really quite drastically and this big
change is to encourage and enable
farmers
to rewild the countryside by which means
letting things go
crazy wild um rather than you know
trampling everything down with uh with
sheep pasture for example it can often
be really really helpful for flood
management to allow a natural habitat to
to grow to allow some of britain's sort
of ancient rainforests to spread to to
allow woodlands to grow
out into kind of fields that have been
left fallow and and potentially
introduce some older kinds of wildlife
as well and it's great for the
environment and great for biodiversity i
mean it's not universally
welcomed i suppose is it i mean yes
brilliant for plant life and all that
but the the reintroduction of beavers
for example in scotland has caused some
farmers difficulties on their land you
know they're good and bad i suppose uh
for the environment
mainly good which is why they've been
reintroduced and they're calling for for
compensation so i mean you know
is this to be broadly welcome do you
think ali
well i think that farmers need to make a
living and they need to be able to use
their land effectively uh in the pursuit
of that uh but i do agree with polly on
this actually i do think it's welcome
and i have to declare an interest anna i
am a national vice president of cpre the
countryside charity and we have been
really focused on uh the both of these
we welcome both of these uh initiatives
both on rewilding and also
more money for local farmers to increase
biodiversity particularly hedgerows is
something that we've been focusing on
because they are a real source of
richness for species for maintenance of
the environment and also for the beauty
and tranquility of the countryside for
us all to enjoy particularly when most
of us have been locked up for a large
part of the last two years it's very
important for mental health to be get
out there into the countryside and
sample the fresh air and look at the
beautiful tranquility of our natural
countryside from nightclubs to rural
protection is there anything you don't
own your hand
anyway to a jolly photograph on the on
the front page of scotland on sunday i
know you love this picture a fresh start
for a new year uh scott's take to the uh
to the outdoors to welcome january 2022.
i'm a short they're called looney dukes
by my scottish producer on tonight um an
outdoor swimmer i guess polly
well yeah i mean anybody who braves
outdoor swimming which is a kind of a
tradition in lots of different parts of
the country a very good friend of mine
was in the in the sea in devon uh this
morning uh and you know and scotland
probably the bravest of the brave
getting in and not even in a wetsuit
this woman she should have gotten on her
frankly
um it is kind of unseasonably mild but i
think the reality is these people would
have been even in the snow
and you know just hats off to them
especially if they're a rainbow hat like
this woman is wearing absolutely and
unseasonably mild we all look uh and
worry about the future the sort of the
dank cloudy
mild wet winters that we we're looking
forward to but um ali i think i should
get to the weather probably shouldn't i
actually on that note but
thank you both very much you need we'll
see you very soon ali and and also polly
lovely to have you both on thank you
very much indeed thank you